let's talk about the purpose of
storytelling during the interview
welcome back to another episode of
Udacity career tips my name is Martin
McGovern and this week we're gonna be
learning about the story of Jeff but
before we do I want to acknowledge how
difficult storytelling is and how
frustrating it can be to be told that
you need to learn an entirely new skill
set on top of the primary skill set that
you just learned for your job I get it
and I'll be the first to admit that I am
not the world's best storyteller but we
all need to know at least the basics of
storytelling because without it people
cannot understand what we are trying to
say which brings us back to Jeff Jeff
and I were working together and he was
crushing it in his job search it wasn't
long before he landed his first
interview and we were combing through a
list of the 30 most asked interview
questions we hopped on skype and
launched into our first question how did
you discover front-end development Jeff
responded how I found it is because I
love technology and I'm interested in
the Internet of Things and then he
stopped his answer sort of touched on
the question but it really didn't go
into much detail I wanted to know what
kinds of Internet of Things devices
inspired him so I went off script and
launched into question number two why do
you like the Internet of Things his
answer because it's the future and it's
fun and exciting
now this answer gave me nothing what's
fun about it what's exciting why is it
the future come on Jeff I need more
details
I asked question number three what does
a futuristic Internet of Things world
look like to you
Jeff's response touch activated or
thought activated devices better
connectivity and easier access to luxury
in life alright we're getting closer
Jeff but you're leaving me hanging on a
lot of details and you kind of ended
that one with a bit of a question mark
at the end Jeff and I paused took a step
back and discussed what was happening
here's what I said to him Jeff the
answers that you're giving to these
questions are way too high level I know
it feels like you're saying something
but from an outsider hearing your words
your
actually not really giving me enough to
go on as an interviewer I'm not able to
read your mind so I need context detail
and specifics in order to be able to
process what it is that you're telling
me Jeff and I shook off the cobwebs and
added more detail to his answers so that
when he got to the interview he would
spend more time painting a picture in
the head of the interviewer rather than
giving these high-level answers and
you'll be happy to hear that Jeff got
the job now I wasn't in the room with
him when he was interviewing but he did
report back that he used stories in
order to build stronger connections with
the interviewer and if I were in the
room this is how I think it might have
gone based off my conversations with
Jeff let's go back to that first
question how did you discover front-end
development
Jeff's answer over the years I've really
come to love the utility of connected
devices and the Internet of Things
specifically Amazon Alexa and Google
home being able to yell the name of my
favorite song or ask a trivia question
from across the room and get a response
truly is an amazing experience building
a seamlessly connected world where our
lives are enhanced by technology is
something that I would like to be a part
of and help build that is how I got
interested in programming and why I'm so
excited for this role now that's a good
story to tell when answering a question
in an interview compare that to the
first way that we answer that question
and you can see how much better this is
at giving context giving specifics and
explaining how this ties in to the job
at hand the reason you're in this room
in this interview today Jeff you got the
job
now this is just the beginning knowing
that you should tell a story and being
able to tell a story are two very
different things
so we'll be making more content around
storytelling during the interview in the
future if you have any other questions
related to the interview please put them
in the comments below and we'll be
addressing them in future videos until
then thank you so much for watching if
you know anyone who is searching for a
job right now
tag them in this video and let them know
you're thinking about them we look
forward to answering more of your job
search questions and wish you the best
of luck in your search